welcome to the urban mind
there's no hole in the ground or
tailings
these minerals are coming from a new
source
electric car batteries
and that's it that's very cool kind of
looks like dirt but kind of looks like
dirt guarantee it's not dirt
that dark shiny material is called Black
Mass it's a concoction of minerals made
from old or defective batteries that
have been shredded and broken down
black mass is the bread and butter of
life cycle a Canadian battery recycler
that wants to make sure the Precious
Minerals and batteries don't go to waste
so how many batteries get recycled at
this facility it's five thousand tons
per year it's a lot of batteries it's a
lot of batteries
some days we're 100 consumer batteries
some days we're 100 EV batteries
Daniel demerse is the plant manager here
at life Cycle's facility in Kingston
Ontario he gave us a close-up look at
how the recycling process works
so are these EV batteries behind us
that's right this is a skid of modules
in an EV car the entire bottom of the
car would be full of these
we take off the bits and pieces that
that we don't want to shred
and then we lift it up onto the conveyor
and send it on its merry way up into the
shredder
the lithium ion battery recycling
industry which barely existed a few
years ago is now booming backed by
federal incentives and big investments
from car manufacturers when we talk
about electric vehicles what we're
really talking about that's new is
batteries Evan pivnick researches what a
future North American Battery Supply
Chain could look like from mining to
manufacturing to recycling
he's with clean energy Canada a think
tank focused on climate and the energy
transition
there really hasn't been a change of
this scale since the last time we moved
from the horse and buggy to the original
combustion engine which you know was a
process that took over 100 years we're
trying to get there in just a couple
decades 20 million passenger EVS are on
the road today and while that's a small
fraction of the global Fleet there could
be 10 times that amount by 2030.
countries including Canada have set
ambitious targets for all new car sales
to be zero emission by the end of the
next decade leaving car manufacturers
scrambling to keep up with demand faced
with the task of reimagining their
fleets and Supply chains
you've got a huge reduction in the
number of parts that are actually needed
but suddenly you need to bring in all
these other materials that go into
batteries lithium Cobalt nickel graphite
and manganese are crucial for these new
batteries
the global race for minerals has begun
but you can't open a mine overnight
mines take a long time to build in most
countries so we've got this supply and
demand crunch that's being forecast
that's made lithium one of the world's
hottest Commodities it's one of the
minerals expected to be in short supply
by 2030.
there's a consensus that more mining
will be necessary to decarbonize Global
Transport but long term even if we could
mine indefinitely there's the question
of whether we should mineral extraction
comes with heavy environmental and human
costs
are we going to be able to get enough
lithium into these battery supply chains
to build the batteries we need to run
the vehicles that's where recycling
comes in
starting in 2030 the first wave of
electric vehicle batteries are expected
to reach their end of life
part of the solution to this supply
problem lies in what happens to those EV
batteries when they run out of juice
and I remember when we started people
say hey why are you like even recovering
lithium lithium is the most valuable
component now those batteries before
starting life cycle AJ kochar worked in
battery manufacturing as an engineer
he watched as lithium-ion became the
most popular battery chemistry and then
started looking into whether any
recyclers were recovering lithium
and to our dismay we found that you
actually can't recover lithium through
these traditional approaches which tend
to burn off materials that they don't
want so that was really an aha moment
for us life cycle doesn't just take in
EV batteries
it also recycles battery manufacturing
scrap and consumer products like laptops
tools and cell phones but the company is
readying itself for a future where
electric vehicles rule the roads
at this facility the first part of the
recycling process takes place shredding
and separating
comes off the conveyor belt it's
submerged in the solution and then goes
through the shredder that's right and
then what comes out of the Shredder
three primary components floating
Plastics
shredded metals and our black moths so
the Black Mass that's what goes into
your future batteries
right now life cycles black mass is sold
to outside vendors but later this year
they will open a new plant in Upstate
New York it's there that they'll use a
new chemical process to recover the
various minerals from the Black Mass
including lithium that plant which they
call the Hub will become one of the
first facilities of its kind in North
America
think of it as Urban Mining and how much
are you able to reuse from those
batteries that you're recycling so we're
getting up to 95 percent recoverable
material from those batteries RJ says
life Cycle's process is greener and
cheaper than traditional Metals
Recycling it's not resource intensive
and produces little waste foreign
but there are other complexities to
consider collection and transportation
are difficult and expensive
EV batteries are heavy and are
classified as hazardous Goods since they
retain a significant charge
though the biggest challenge battery
recyclers say they face is getting their
hands on a consistent Supply
electric vehicle batteries are lasting
longer than expected but life cycle and
others remain confident that come 2030
there will be more than enough batteries
to go around
personally I see it increasing I mean
this is the way everything is going
you're going to need to build more of
these if anything to to kind of keep up
with demand
I would expect yes and you said you come
from the mining World previous to this
yeah I do why did you become involved
with recycling I like the idea of being
more part of the solution and Mining
always has its risks the mining always
has its environmental hazards the
environmental footprint here is very low
and it's very appealing to me
life cycle is on its way to being a
global leader in battery recycling
expanding its reach across the U.S and
Europe and its competitors here in
Canada are not far behind
so as we see electric vehicle demand
explode and you know all of the
different mines that are going to need
to be stood up there's a really big
desire to see recycling play a larger
and larger role how quickly recycling is
able to feed in a sizable share of
critical minerals that's a little bit
unknown
battery recycling has the potential to
solve multiple problems at once
with a new stream of battery grade
materials coming from recyclers it could
reduce the need for Mining and all the
impacts that come along with it and
because recycling is generally cheaper
than mining it could reduce the cost of
batteries most of which are made in
China
that though has been getting challenged
as sort of the geopolitical climate we
now live in starts to see changes where
the lowest cost producer is no longer
the only thing that matters
that's what sparked a massive push to
bring battery making home to North
America
new battery plants are popping up across
the U.S and Canada giving recyclers the
market they need to thrive this solves a
problem gets it out of the landfill gets
it back into industry gets it back into
your next device
[Music]